timbuk2 a legendary city that's still
practically deserted two years after
Islamist insurgents fled hai dharam alia
has stayed he's one of the city's unsung
heroes he risked his life to save
cultural treasures from the terrorists
for five generations now Malaya's family
has run a library in Timbuktu it housed
and preserved priceless manuscripts some
dating back almost a thousand years but
two years ago things changed since the
jihadi fighters marched into the city
the shelves have been filled with
nothing but desert sand people used to
come here every morning to study or read
there were desks over there and the
shelves were full but then the gunmen
came and put an end to all that but
Malaya wasn't going to let the city's
cultural heritage be destroyed without a
fight he hid manuscripts down the legs
of his trousers and in his pockets and
smuggled them back to his house he even
removed the sign outside the library and
took it home with him to avoid any
suspicion
since then he's been storing some three
thousand manuscripts at home some of the
texts were written by Islamic scholars
others are works about science and
geography Malaya has seven crates of
them I'm the eldest in my family's
that's why it's my responsibility I'm
doing things the way my ancestors
prescribed I'm not allowed to sell them
to anyone I can't even give him away in
a baboon attack okay it goes without
saying that he wanted to stop this
legacy falling into the hands of the
terrorists who arrived in early 2012 al
Qaeda in Maghreb Mirage a militia and
the Malian group Ansar Dine seized large
parts of northern Mali back then at
first they fought alongside to our egg
rebels but later turned against them
Malian troops were only able to repel
the Islamists with the help of the
French army this exclusive footage taken
by a Malian cameraman shows the cruelty
of the rampaging terrorists
the damage that the islamists inflicted
on the culture of the region is perhaps
most clearly visible at the ahmed baba
institute in the heart of Timbuktu here
the jihad is burned more than four
thousand manuscripts one of hadera
Malays friends is the deputy director
here two years after the attack he's
still coming to terms with it since it
is if a neck and neck do it had nothing
to do with the ideology the Islamists
were here for 10 months and didn't burn
anything they only destroyed the
manuscripts the night they fled they did
it to spite the world because they knew
their cultural and scientific value they
knew just how important they were their
intention was to anger Timbuktu Mali and
the international community even though
hai dharam allah's manuscript collection
hardly earns him any money and he
struggles to feed his family he's proud
that he has done what his ancestors
would have wanted saved every single one
of the unique cultural treasures for
posterity